[Música]
Hola hoy en sciencelich que veríamos
acercarnos de la velocidad de la luz
embarquemos en una nave espacial
acelerando desde la tierra hacia el
espacio alejándonos cada vez más rápido
de nuestro planeta
que veríamos al acelerar Qué efectos
ópticos pueden producirse Y si
intentásemos superar la velocidad de la
luz curvando el espacio-tiempo como las
películas de ciencia ficción que
veríamos las respuestas a estas
preguntas servirá de pretexto para
explorar múltiples fenómenos de nuestro
universo y para sumergirnos en el
corazón de las teorías de la relatividad
nuestra nave espacial está inicialmente
inmóvil una vez con combustible
empezamos a acelerar
imaginemos que su sistema de propulsión
nos permite acelerar permanentemente
todo el tiempo que queramos
a medida que ganamos velocidad nos
alejamos de la Tierra
al acelerar cada vez más se podría
pensar que la velocidad de la nave
acabaría por volverse inviable pero no
la velocidad no tiene ningún efecto en
nuestro cuerpo cuando un tren pasa al
costado de las ventanas del nuestro es
imposible percibir si es nuestro tren el
que está detenido del mismo modo dentro
de la nave no podemos sentir su
velocidad sino únicamente su aceleración
el impulso de los motores que nos
presionan contra nuestros asientos si
este impulso es razonable será
perfectamente soportable durante todo
nuestro viaje
sin embargo existe un riesgo asociado a
la velocidad de la nave el riesgo de
colisión
una sola partícula de polvo causaría
daños colosales sino se impactará
afortunadamente nuestra nave está
equipada con un campo de fuerza que
repele los objetos peligrosos y nos
permite volar libremente en el espacio
al acelerar aparece un primer efecto
óptico sorprendente las estrellas que
tenemos enfrente a medida que nos
acercamos a ellas parecen alejarse poco
a poco el cielo se contrae frente a
nosotros
para entenderlo mejor pensemos en una
situación similar estar en un coche
conduciendo a gran velocidad y que
empiece a llover
la lluvia cae verticalmente de arriba a
abajo pero cuando el coche avanza recibe
las gotas en la parte delantera del
parabrisas
desde su punto de vista la lluvia no
parece venir desde arriba sino desde el
frente cuanto más se acelera más parece
llover de frente
en nuestra nave espacial el efecto
óptico que percibimos es perfectamente
análogo la luz de las estrellas viene de
una determinada dirección Pero a medida
que aceleramos los rayos de luz nos
parecen llegar cada vez más de enfrente
Este es el efecto de aberración de la
luz
a medida que la luz se enfoca delante de
nosotros la intensidad de la luz aumenta
mientras que detrás de nosotros la
imagen de las estrellas se hace más
amplia y oscura
la aberración de la luz que nos rodea da
lugar a otro extraño fenómeno imaginemos
que pasamos a través de una enorme
cuadrícula que representa el tejido del
espacio en circunstancias normales las
líneas que la componen aparecen como
líneas rectas que discurren frente a
nosotros debido al efecto de perspectiva
[Música]
Pero a medida que aceleramos con el paso
de los días el fenómeno de aberración
distorsiona la imagen del cielo que nos
rodea la cuadrícula parece contraerse
hacia adelante y las líneas rectas se
curvan
si pasáramos junto a un objeto inmóvil
este parecería estar ligeramente
inclinado hacia nosotros
se trata del fenómeno de rotación de
Terra el pene Rose como nos movemos muy
deprisa las imágenes de los objetos
parecen contraerse delante de nosotros y
la perspectiva está muy distorsionada
[Música]
a menudo se dice que Cuanto más lejos se
mira en el espacio más atrás se mira en
el tiempo en efecto la luz que recibimos
de una estrella lejana ha tenido que
recorrer miles de millones de kilómetros
antes de alcanzarnos la luz tarda cierto
tiempo en llegar hasta nosotros En
consecuencia vemos la estrella tal y
como era en el pasado cuando emitía esta
luz quizá hace varios miles de años no
sabemos si ha cambiado ya
desde nuestra nave espacial se produce
el mismo fenómeno a medida que nos
alejamos de la tierra la luz del planeta
tarda cada vez más en llegar a nosotros
si pudiéramos ampliar la imagen con un
telescopio veríamos a la gente la tierra
moviéndose a cámara lenta cada Tic Tac
del reloj en la tierra tarda más y más
en llegar a nosotros esto se llama el
efecto Doppler recibimos los rayos de
luz a cámara lenta y su intensidad
parece debilitarse a medida que la
imagen del planeta tiende al rojo
[Música]
frente a nosotros se produce el efecto
contrario las estrellas parecen ser cada
vez más brillantes desplazándose hacia
el azul y su relojes parecen ir más
rápido
[Música]
con equipos suficientemente precisos
podríamos medir los fenómenos de
aberración y de efecto Doppler desde
nuestros primeros días en el espacio
pero si decidiéramos detenernos y
regresar a la tierra estos efectos no
tendrían ninguna repercusión son solo
ilusiones ópticas debidas a la forma en
que recibimos la luz cuando nos movemos
pero después de varios cientos de días
los motores nos empujan cada vez más
rápido y la nave empieza a acercarse a
la velocidad de la luz a tales
velocidades ciertos fenómenos dejarán de
ser meras ilusiones ópticas entrarán en
juego efectos físicos reales
consecuencias irreversibles la
relatividad especial empieza a
intervenir
una primera consecuencia de la
relatividad es lo que se conoce como
dilatación del tiempo nuestro universo
es un enorme tejido de cuatro
dimensiones llamado espacio-tiempo tres
dimensiones del espacio y una del tiempo
en el espacio tiempo todos los cuerpos
incluso los inmóviles trazan una
trayectoria ya que todos se mueven hacia
Su futuro antes del despegue nuestra
nave que estaba inmóvil se dirigía en la
misma dirección que la tierra hacia el
futuro Pero a medida que aumentamos la
velocidad y nos alejamos cada vez más
nuestra trayectoria se desvía
progresivamente del planeta ahora el eje
llamado tiempo ya no está alineado con
el eje tiempo de los habitantes de la
Tierra
si decidiéramos dar la vuelta y regresar
nuestros relojes habrían medido un
tiempo diferente habríamos envejecido
menos que los terrícolas ya que nuestras
trayectorias en espacio tiempo habrían
sido distintas
otro efecto fundamental de la
relatividad especial es la llamada
contracción de la longitud cuando un
cuerpo se mueve cerca de la velocidad de
la luz su longitud se contrae en la
dirección de su movimiento
desde la nave todo el universo parece
moverse hacia atrás así para nosotros el
Universo se contrae según nuestro
movimiento
en particular la duración del viaje a
nuestro destino es más corta de lo que
podríamos haber pensado ojo no se trata
de un efecto óptico sino de otros
fenómeno físico y bien concreto Si
intentásemos alcanzar una estrella
lejana el viaje nos parecería en
realidad más corto tardando menos tiempo
Cuanto más rápido viajásemos
así contrariamente la creencia popular
Sería posible viajar miles de años luz
en pocos segundos
en el caso extremo de viajar casi a la
velocidad de la luz cualquier viaje
parecería incluso instantáneo
[Música]
sin embargo para las personas que
permanecerían en la tierra ya hubiesen
transcurrido varios miles de años
la contracción de las distancias es un
fenómeno bastante real Pero visualmente
sería difícil de percibir
para entender Por qué imaginemos que
atravesamos la órbita de un planeta
como se mueve muy rápido hacia nosotros
el planeta se contrae en su longitud
pero no olvidemos Cuanto más lejos en el
espacio observamos más atrás en el
tiempo miramos respecto a nosotros la
parte trasera del planeta está más lejos
en el espacio que la parte delantera la
imagen que recibimos de la parte
posterior del planeta ha tardado más en
llegar hasta nosotros la vemos tal y
como era en el pasado
en resumen aunque esté contraído el
planeta no parece estarlo visualmente
Por qué recibimos la imagen de su parte
delantera y trasera de modo intercalado
en lugar de estar contraído parece estar
girado sobre sí mismo
se trata de un fenómeno que ya hemos
visto la rotación de terrier Rose
cuando nos movemos muy deprisa y miramos
a nuestro lado el borde de los objetos
parece más corto en la dirección de
nuestro movimiento esto puede
interpretarse como una contracción de
las distancias o como una rotación como
un efecto de perspectiva
por la misma razón una persona que nos
viese pasar no vería realmente nuestra
nave contraída sino girada sobre sí
misma
[Música]
a medida que avanzamos nuestro campo de
visión sigue contrayéndose se
intensifica delante de nosotros mientras
que todo se vuelve negro detrás
Pero a medida que aceleramos más y más
podríamos esperar alcanzar la velocidad
de la luz que veríamos entonces
Esta es quizá una de las cuestiones más
fundamentales de la relatividad no
Aunque la nave se alegre continuamente
nunca alcanzaremos la velocidad de la
luz
la velocidad de la luz es absoluta
Incluso si se corre detrás de un rayo de
luz desde nuestro punto de vista este
siempre escapará a la misma velocidad
se puede acelerar todo lo que se quiera
pero aunque desde la tierra parezca que
se acerca la velocidad de la luz desde
su punto de vista es como si seguir en
móvil la luz se le escapa
inexorablemente
[Música]
en resumen estrictamente imposible
superar o incluso alcanzar la velocidad
de la luz en el mejor de los casos
nuestra nave seguirá acelerando
Eternamente y nuestro campo de visión
será cada vez más pequeño hasta que se
convierta en un punto infinitamente
brillante frente a nosotros rodeado de
un cielo completamente negro al movernos
casi a la velocidad de la luz todos los
efectos ópticos adquieren dimensiones
extremas todos los rayos de luz parecen
venir de frente
en nuestro marco de referencia el
universo está extremadamente contraído
como una fina tela que cruzaríamos de un
lado a otro en una fracción de segundo
para una persona en la tierra nos
movemos a la velocidad de la luz pero
para nosotros el viaje parece
instantáneo nos movemos infinitamente
rápido
En conclusión nada puede desplazarse más
rápido que la luz en el espacio
pero podría dar una forma muy
especulativa de eludir esta prohibición
en efecto nada impide que el propio
espacio se mueva más rápido
la teoría la relatividad general nos
enseña que el tejido del espacio-tiempo
es Dinámico puede curvarse de muchas
maneras
podríamos imaginar la creación de una
burbuja de espacio alrededor de nuestra
nave que propulsaríamos más rápido que
la luz es lo que llamamos referencia a
la ciencia ficción un empuje por
curvatura ya no se trataría de movernos
por el espacio sino de propulsar el
propio tejido del universo nuestra nave
permanecería inmóvil navegando en una
ola de espacio-tiempo superlumínico
una estructura de este tipo puede
parecer inverosímil Y actualmente se
considera imposible de conseguir un
empuje por curvatura requeriría que el
espacio-tiempo fuera torcido por
inmensas cantidades de masa negativa una
forma de materia que a priori no existe
en el universo dicho esto las
matemáticas siempre nos permiten soñar y
podemos calcular lo que veríamos en una
tal situación si lo miramos desde el
exterior cuando pasa por delante de
nosotros el impulso por curvatura parece
aparecer de repente la curvatura del
espacio-tiempo forma una especie de
lente que se mueve y se divide en dos
una parte que se mueve hacia adelante y
la otra hacia atrás
Esto se debe a que la luz viaja más
lentamente que el propio mecanismo de
empuje cuando se aproxima aún no ha
tenido tiempo de alcanzarnos y cuando
pasa frente a nosotros recibimos
simultáneamente dicha luz que aún no
había llegado a nosotros y los rayos que
se emitieron después
desde el interior veríamos un cielo
contraído hacia adelante y muy brillante
detrás de nosotros el universo
aparecería extremadamente oscuro y toda
una zona del cielo parecería haber
desaparecido la luz que emite es
demasiado lenta para alcanzarnos un cono
del universo permanece invisible detrás
de nosotros
[Música]